good morning everybody welcome to mid
Suffolk district council cabinet meeting
apologies for absence
we have apologies from councillor
Jessica Fleming thank you item 2
declaration of interest by councillors
item 3 MC a 19-13 to confirm the minutes
of the meeting held on the 4th of
November I'd only got one comment which
is on item 59 future vision management
options
that's just January 2020 I believe
that's now coming in February 2020
they're really happy that I sign item 4
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme none received item 5 questions by
councillors none received item 6 matters
referred by the overview and scrutiny or
the joint audit and standards committee
dev on item 7 the forthcoming decisions
list we're not going to go through it
it's on the website if anybody wants to
have a look at it
item 8 mca 19 / 31 the three-year
funding for mid Suffolk Citizens Advice
Kancil flat Thank You chair it is with
pleasure that I present this report to
cabinet as fellow councillors will be
aware Citizens Advice provide a vital
lifeline for some of our most vulnerable
residents our council is the most
significant single funder for mid
Suffolk Citizens Advice and as a cabinet
member I have been in discussion with
officers for some time regarding the
security of their funding while we have
just commenced a Community Grants review
I have been keen to bring this item in
advance of the outcomes from that review
because I recognize the importance of a
more secure funding platform for the
Citizens Advice and it is on that basis
that I present this paper tear the paper
speaks for itself and I don't intend to
spend a long time introducing it so on
that basis I would like to present this
report to you and propose the
recommendations contained in paragraphs
3.1 and 3.2 to provide a three year
funding agreement to mid Suffolk
Citizens Advice thank you and I'd ask
for a seconder as somebody who's
previously used some of my locality
budget to fund the Citizens Advice I
really welcome this support for them and
I'm very happy to second it does anybody
have any questions
cancer field
thank you I know for sure it was a
question I wanted to express our total
support for what you're trying to do I
think excellent and perhaps a brief
explanation there is some comment in
here about a joint scrutiny activity
across the whole of the county I have to
say of being some more polls to get into
the council the County Council involved
in that as far as chair of scrutiny
committee the real reason being that we
trashed it to death in November last
year
when we looked at the proposed County
budget and got precisely no well
precisely now where's an exaggeration we
did manage to get half the reduction in
funding we seen did for up for any
period it was going to be a stage
funding and I do notice the county
budget this year does include some
reinstatement of funding short term only
used something like hundred ten thousand
so less than less than half what used to
be provided but it is an improvement
I would hope to bring that up at our
scrutiny of the county budget which is
tomorrow so I think just Express
appalled and the thought that the CIB
certainly the data they gave us loss
last year showed a lot of clarity of
thoughts a lot of understanding of what
they're doing of who they're targeting I
thought it was going exemplary in
expressing the activities organization
we all know is extremely valuable so
they are so it's not a question but
that's acceptable and yes the whole idea
of getting everybody involved in that
larger scrutiny was to hopefully force
the hand to some people to get more
money but I think some of our partners
have agreed to work with us and we
welcome for character joining in and
seeing what they can do for us this year
with their budget thank you
if we were allowed more than just
questions can I fully support this but
can I just make a comment in response to
what counsel Flatman was just said and
that is the main purpose of this across
County task force was not necessarily to
force anybody's hand but to raise the
profile of Citizens Advice because the
people who use it desperately needed but
the majority of the population just
think that it will go on forever and we
need you to make it clear to the
residents of mid Suffolk and beyond that
this is a charity and it needs funding
but I do fully support this and I would
hope that it will be a rolling three
years that we're not going to nurse wait
for three years before we make another
decision because they do need the
certainty of funding
and yes totally Keith but also I think
we have got to be realistic and with us
agreeing to fund for three years then we
are hoping that they might be able to
attract other other funding as well but
we are not just the only people who are
going to fund okay we've had a proposer
and a seconder can I have a show of
hands in support please anybody games
motion is carried
thank you
I to 9 MCA 19 / 32 introduction of a
council tax penalties policy council
Whitehead thank you madam chairman I'm
pleased to introduce cabinet paper mca
1932 on the insertion of a council tax
penalties policy which starts on page 39
of our electronic pact now local
authority is a task for collection of
council attacks they are legally
entitled to obtain information from
residents owners and managing agents to
help identify the person liable for the
payment of council tax a shared revenues
partnership SRP carries out this
function on behalf of mid Suffolk Baber
and Ipswich Borough Council our civil
penalties can be issued where a person
fails to supply within 21 days certain
information requested by the council or
if within 21 days of a change which
affects council tax registration or
entitlement to discount exemption or
council tax reduction in our report
paragraph 4.4 sets out the circumstances
in which the council may impose a
penalty now currently none of the SRP
partners issue penalties but all three
are now set to bring forward such a
policy to their respective cabinets for
approval when I became a member of the
shared revenues partnership committee
several years ago I was happy to learn
that the SRP had undertaken a review of
single resident discounts as intuitively
it seemed to me this to be an area most
open to deception and fraud each year
the SRP committee been given metrics
showing the number of discounts removed
by this exercise and the resulting
increase in council tax collected and
each year we've agreed to continue this
exercise which is funded by the SRP
partners Suffolk County Council and
Suffolk police and crime Commissioner to
me it's a no brainer and I'm pleased
that there's a general consensus on this
matter by the aforementioned bodies but
the introduction of a council tax
penalties policy should further
encourage Custer
to keep taxpayers details up-to-date
thus ensuring the tax base is as
accurate as possible and at more causal
taxes collected the policy itself is set
out on pages 45 to 48 may believe that
it's a measured and reasonable approach
and set out plain English and
accordingly I'm happy to impose a
recommendation for implementation by
omit Suffolk that recommendations set
out in paragraph 3.1 on page 39 I will
be asking for someone to second that
recommendation but for now it'll also
like to introduce Andrew Wilcock who's
with us he's the SRP Operations Manager
he's here to assist me in answering any
questions of members may have on the
policy and procedures thank you we have
a second I'd like to second to
recommendations does anybody have any
questions either for John or for Andrew
sorry counselor field no I'm waiting to
see if there are other questions first
and just just really the whole issue I
suppose that concern me a bit about this
policy understand that sort of drawing
over but the issue that you know when
you're trying to get the donkey to move
you need a camera and a stick and this
seems to be a bit of an application of
the punishment mistake and I'm slightly
concerned there they're fairly happy
that that is applied to people who are
in they sort of won't party category for
council tax or information about council
tax but somewhat concerned that it may
cause problems with the people who are
in the comp a category so additional
penalties will not help people who
really don't know where the next plane
is coming from so it really was just
gonna ask portfolio you know how he's
gonna address that I can see this is a
voice of bureaus involved and that seems
good but how can we be sure that we are
actually encouraging those who are in
the one PI category or won't give
information category to aunty to change
their behavior but not punishing people
who are in dreadful problems to start
off with thank you I think that well
within that policy we'll see how much
discretion it is giving to our
operations manager in terms of imposing
these penalties and it says each case we
looked at on a case-by-case basis I
think we do need the carrot and stick I
mean I looked at the definition of fraud
because it's obviously anti-fraud policy
so it's important what does fraud mean
frauds definers wrongful criminal
deception intended to result in
financial gain and frosti finders deceit
trickery and an intentional perversion
of the truth so from that point of view
come we do need the stick but at the
same time we've got the discretion
within the policy that's how its applied
any more questions
counselor coupe yes so it wonder if we
have any idea how many of these people
are in the sort of deliberate fraud
category I don't think the paper gives
us an idea of how many how many people
even though are in arrears but how many
of those are in a position where they're
fraudulently child again an advantage
and how many are in a position where
they're totally just unable to find good
approaches as to bring Andrew in here
because I say over the last few years
we've been looking at this single
discount and I know there's a lot of
work on that practically just giving a
bit of a background to that yep Thank
You chair I think the first thing to
recognize council tax records the
majority people we have a name and we
have address so until we get some sort
of engagement we don't understand what
people circumstances are if you purely
look on the single person discount each
year we taken away around 250 cases
where they have failed to inform us
they're no longer entitled they haven't
been investigated for fraud so they
haven't been classified as fraud they're
purely people that have failed to tell
us they're no longer entitled and in
terms of forging I'd turn activity i
haven't got handed of those figures but
you know we are focusing on the single
person discount things at this point in
time so he's around about 250 cases a
year
so proposer and a seconder can I have a
show of hands in favor does that include
you David
passed unanimously
[Music]
thank you again madam chairman so I'm
now pleased to introduce cabinet paper
mca 1933 on the adoption of the council
tax Citizens Advice collection protocol
and this starts on page 49 of our trunk
packet in the report we read that the
level of council tax outstanding in
England at the end of the last financial
year was 3.2 billion versus 10 percent
increase from the prior year and
charities are warning that castle tax
arrears now rival credit card debts as
their biggest concern it's obviously
important that we protect the public
purse and maximize our collection but
SRP has been engaging with Citizens
Advice to review the processes in place
for collection and benchmarking these
against the standards set out in the
Citizens Advice protocol if collection
process can be improved and more early
interventions to assist residents
struggling their council tax payments
then we should be able to help prevent
further charges being applied we should
reduce council sorry reduce collection
costs and obviously alleviate stress on
those involved and adopting this
Citizens Advice council tax protocol
should help achieve this protocol itself
is set out in our papers on pages 53 to
60 I'm pleased to propose a
recommendation set out in paragraph 3.1
on page 49 that myth Civic approves the
adoption of the Citizens Advice council
tax protocol just note that needs a an S
after the word citizen because it's
Citizens Advice the protocol that's
detailed in Appendix A and would look to
someone to second that recommendation
thank you Brewster happy to say the
second this recommendation chair thank
you does anybody have any questions
counselor field hockey pan have a
similar comments here before and
obviously a good protocol to adopt once
concern us first laws in the the
suggestions that it's Universal Credit
is driving a dramatic increase in in
council tax backlog so at the present
time I just wonder whether you could
refresh my memory or more actions which
Suffolk takes to ensure that we help
people out of their problems in that
area rather than push them back into
them council why did you just put a bit
of meat on those buttons
Thank You chair terms of customers in
receipt a universal credit they're also
entitled to council tax reduction which
if they get full entitlement and working
age they receive a reduction in ninety
five percent we then obviously take
whatever is left due to be paid spread
that over the whole of the financial
year if people are struggling again we
will engage and redistribute those
payments and what we have found over the
last twelve months is customers claim
universal credit that failed to claim
caps tax reduction so again we're
looking to make some slight tweaks to
next year's schemes as long as the
Department of Work and Pensions inform
us there on Universal Credit will grant
the character tax reduction but as long
as we get back engagement we do have
lots of different arrangement types in
place and again we also work with the
device and the quarterly meeting so if
they've got customers that happy to
engage with them but perhaps not with us
then we will work with CA B directly so
anybody else have any questions
so I have a proposal and a seconder may
I have a show of hands in favor please
thank you passed unanimously
item 11 mca 1934 there's the sil
expenditure business plan January 2020
cancel burn thank about if Jim yes this
report seeks to contain the approval of
cabinet for medical business plans
January 2020 this business plan focuses
on one single bid being m14 - 18 the
silk business plan that does however
provide an update of today progress
position on all those syllables which
have previously been approved in bid
rounds 1 2 2 3 now Silva dem 14 - 18 was
originally submitted in bid round 1 and
was for a school expansion for 1.2
million pounds no planning permission
has been granted from the detailed
design and the amount of the bid was
based on old cost multipliers the bid
was attempt to be invalid at that time
following a lot of detailed discussion a
revised SIL bid accompanied by a
business plan with a detailed design was
submitted on the 10th of October 2019
this information has been followed up
with further information relating to
costings and this information made to
celebrate valid and capable of being
progressed the use of the use of new
cost multipliers and the final design
for the expansion of staff planned high
school means that the project to expand
the school with an additional hundred
and twenty-five secondary school places
and 15 new sixth-form places will result
in a total project cost
of nearly 3 million pounds excluding vhe
which SCC can recover and a cell bit of
almost 2.5 million points the reason why
this bid is being determined
independently of the other outstanding
bids is that the housing growth that has
caused the need for the school expansion
has already taken place in a number of
the locations that within the catchment
area these developments have triggered
the need for school expansion and for
this to be fully constructed and capable
of being used ready for the September
term in 2020 this is the first high
school expansion project and is classed
as essential infrastructure in the joint
infrastructure delivery plan planning
permission was granted for the scheme
which is a subject to this sill bid by a
favorable decision at Suffolk County
counties County Council's development
and regulation committee on the 29th of
October 2019 we do have Christine here
thank goodness because it's quite a
technical quite a technical paper and
she is far better situated for answering
any questions you might have than I am
but before we start that I would like to
propose a recommendation and I look for
a second to thank you have a seconder
I'm happy to second that recommendation
Thank You councillor whited
does anybody have any questions
councillor Brewster Thank You villager
um yes I if Christine could possibly
answer these ones and it's it's just
some queries and some clarification I
really I'm looking for at a previous
meeting I did say when still market was
list I'm talking about 4.3 at the moment
on page 65 I did ask if still market
which had been missed off that list was
within the catchment area of Scotland
High School and the quick I would extend
that question a little bit because it
has been included in this list of bullet
points under 4.3 I'm just no wondering
if in fact it is
Cedar's Park development which is part
of the catchment area for stir up in
high school I don't know if you'd like
me to I've got several questions here
actually so with it sorry
see you now Christine I don't know if
you'd rather answer these as we go
through yep
sorry pressing the wrong button sorry
about that I looked at this again this
morning and thought it was a bit odd
that stone market was in the catchment
area but I think you're right in so far
as the big Cedars park development there
is a boundary on that park somewhere
between stone market and Stowe upland
and certain parts of that big
development do actually point towards
Stowe upland and are within that
catchment area so I haven't got in
effect an exact answer for you in
relation to why we plucked out stone
market there it may well be that there
are one or two pieces of development in
stone market which do actually point
towards that as a catchment yeah see
this part thank you very much
just moving on obviously there is a lot
of quite a substantial sum of money
coming from the Cedars Park area to stop
at high school which I don't actually
have an objection with it at all but is
this money all the money the percentage
of money put into the strategic part
originally it's it's just centred a bit
knowledge on on that side of it I'm
talking about the overall strategic part
as well yes so in terms of in within the
SIL business plan you'll see the
recommendation is to spend everything in
the strategic pop which is 1.1 million
that's because a high school as you can
see from your papers and four point
three in your cabinet papers does cover
a wide catchment and when we were
putting money into a strategic pot we
always said that that money would be for
more than one parish so for the bigger
issues which are bigger projects which
this is
what we've done is we've looked at all
the ring-fenced money so members may
recall that when we take money we save
all the liability notice values where
we've got developments of over tend
Wellings we save all that money and we
put that into an account against that
parish so that when we need the
infrastructure for that parish we can
use that money to provide the
infrastructure so for the Stowe upland
catchment there is some I think of nine
hundred and fifty three thousand
approximately so we've taken all that
money all the strategic money and then a
proportion of the local infrastructure
fund to be able to afford it and what
that does it gives you let me just say
looking at my papers
you would have 1.3 million left to deal
with bid round for the remainder of
about standing bids and I think you've
got approximately 1.5 left in the ring
fenced fund so this doesn't exhaust all
the SIL monies
it's not sorry if I can reassure people
obviously we take money every day so we
are saving money every day towards
replenishing that strategic pot so it
won't remain at naught and what we do is
twice a year when we do the neighborhood
sill payouts that's when we adjust all
the pot sizes so that we make sure that
we we have everything accurately
recorded thank you very much and really
part of that question was just asking is
there a need once so money has gone into
the strategic part to show actually
where it comes from which which silly
error it comes from what development
area sorry when we made the decision to
save our monies into a strategic pot and
to in a local pot it would be very very
complicated in fact it near impossible
to try and find out where all of those
monies have come from you know we
focused our attention really on making
sure that for every 10 dwellings and
above we make sure that we we capture
that money and put it against a
particular parish so to record all of
our monies like that I need a few more
people and you know I'm not sure what we
would what benefits there would be but
that money that is saved into the
strategic pot comes from the whole of
the district I do say there could be
some complications there in doing that
and on page 75 under 9.7 it's just a
typo actually that round bid round 5
opens in May 19
sorry 2029 which i think is probably a
little incorrect
you're correct
anyone questions counselor field thank
you
just three I think one I wondered
understood that the County Council no
longer has a concept of catchment areas
for schools the pupil allocation is
depend is just to one person's closest
school
I wondered how that impacts their sums
the second one I suppose is looking at
the terrible of SIL there's good cases
with large developments where sillies
collected in a file used a manner but it
may well be that something like a school
development needs to be carried out in
advance you can't you can't build a
class for three and a half pupils or
something you have to build them in a
certain modules I just wondered what is
there a process then for the county to
bid furthest as sum of money to build an
entire school and it to be assured that
he will eventually receive an
appropriate amount of SIL so that he can
borrow short term to build the schools
and then regain the cash from the silk
so just something on the complexity
there the third one was I noticed the
parish council I think it was or
startling council was it was concerned
about the thought that this particular
school is owned by a private company and
therefore this represents if you like
her a three million pound government
gift to her to a private company who I
guess could cease operations next week
if things were really bad so I just
wonder what was thought was on that I
don't didn't see an answer to that
question for more stark wonder I think
Christine let me start with some of the
answers to that question and then
perhaps I can introduce you to Johanna
fellows who's from the school's
infrastructure team from Suffolk County
Council and I'll take you so far
journals will finish so you mentioned
about the three million and about
academies so the DfE guidance actually
talks about developer contributions
being secured whether they be academies
or not academies don't get government
funding and developer contributions are
necessary in order to provide
infrastructure whether it has an academy
status so they all the academies that we
have within the district it would be
intended that if extensions were to be
provided and that money as long as
they're extensions to schools rather
than these schools and that money would
would come from SIL on the on the
question of forward funding I mean a lot
of work happens before a SIL bid is
actually submitted we've been meeting
regularly with Suffolk County Council at
schools infrastructure team for a long
period now we do actually look at what
is needed for the growth but also what
would future-proof it and what would be
affordable and from that we get to a
situation where in this particular bid
we we've got fourteen of the amount of
places that are being provided which is
being provided according to basic needs
so it's not all coming from developer
contributions and on the catchment area
side yep so just on the catchment areas
there is no catchment guarantee anymore
but when it comes to developers and
planning the infrastructure we still use
the catchment areas and where the
general population is particularly for
the high schools as it covers a large
area to look at where those developments
see it
and then therefore where the
infrastructure needs to go to
accommodate those peoples obviously
there is people preference might take
children elsewhere but generally they
will be the infrastructure will be
provided within the area that the
development is and for the nearest
school for that so obviously for the
high school it covers a wide area for
primary schools much more concentrated
towards those smaller catchment areas
but we doing use the catchment areas
when we're looking for development
contributions thank you could I come
back it's difficult getting stories of
certainly a high school in my County
division that's being having pupils
directed to it from closest pupils or in
the theoretical catchment area of other
schools so it does seem to be an issue
there that how can I particular school
gain the funds it needs to expand if
you're doing those calculations or
you're doing the availability of money
calculations most on catchment areas
that don't actually function when it
comes to direction of pupils I think
it's almost a catch-22 isn't it you've
got to provide the infrastructure within
the catchment areas for at the school to
be able to offer enough places for the
children arising from the catchment area
so if we don't provide the
infrastructure at this school it almost
becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy
doesn't help that those children then
can't go to the school so we need to
provide the places for the peoples that
we've the pupil yield that we can sure
is coming from the developments within
the catchment area councillor Willem
Thank You chair I've got several points
um to follow up and what's already been
said I can't confirm that students are
all over so well could come to snow
upland High School
many of them live nearer to stone market
high school into snow upland but that's
that's parental choice or
there are quite a number of pupils from
Stowe upland they've come up to its
reach to separate one pupil choice can I
also say it was not the Parish Council
who had concerns about the Academy
status that was something that county
councillor Gary green had a beef about
and I didn't understand that the parish
council didn't understand it but he
certainly had a being his bonnet about
the academy status and I don't want to
be associated with that and nor does the
parish council can I start by saying I
fully support the principle of having a
high quality sustainable Sixth Form at
Stowe upland it is important and that is
included in the snow upland neighborhood
plan and I note that you're being asked
to approve the bid subject to completion
of a Community User Agreement and these
discussions around the community User
Agreement need to be widened in my view
because there are a lot of issues such
as parking issues and one of the as a
small point perhaps but the new car park
planning permission is for daytime use
and yet we see in here that if that
doesn't sit well with the suggestion
that the University of sufferer will run
evening classes there so there there are
things like that spur to need to be
sorted out there is no parking provision
for sixth formers and yet some 30% of
six warmers in the survey last summer
term come to school by car but by their
own car they drive 30 percent if this is
if this grows to say 206 warmers as as
is the long term plan that 70 cars that
need to be accommodated unfortunately at
the first attempt to get planning
permission Suffolk County Council was
saying that they could use the village
hall car park
but the but the village hall trustees
have said no that's not that's not
permitted I mean they need a they need
all the spaces there for village hall
users who have paid to hire in each or
yeah I mean in the in the widget on page
64 it says that there is car parking
space for sixth formers but there is
there is none shown on the drawing that
does need to be sorted the other thing
is that there are concerns that there
are other phases of development we know
that there are other phases develop of
development because the parish counts
were being told that book but there's no
indication of what they are this this
block will have four classrooms if there
are if they really are going to be 206
formers it's going to be fairly big
class sizes I mean nothing of what I
said wants to hold up
the agreement to the bid but I think we
need to add on that the discussions need
to be widened it's not just who can use
which room on which on which days and
for how long and how much it's going to
cost it's got to be much wider than that
so my question is how can the district
council ensure that the concerns of
local residents and the parish council
can be addressed before the extension is
brought into use I'd have to say the
work has already started on-site so you
know it is we are on a tight time scale
here but we do need to have discussions
about these these outstanding issues
thank you as councillor Ellen may know
there has been a meeting called for the
14th of January with the Academy with
the parish with yourself and with the
schools infrastructure team not only to
look at the prospect of a further
leisure project on
the site but I'm hoping to use that as
an opportunity to talk about the
community user agreement clearly that
does need to be a matter which is not
just restricted to the town you know to
the district council or to Suffolk
County Council but it does need to be a
wider debate to make sure that we get
the community use of the building
secured and you know issues that you've
mentioned about the amount of occupation
on the site of sixth-form you've
mentioned 30 percent I think I put in my
papers six percent I think that's
because it's an ever-evolving number as
more students pass their test during the
year the number grows and then he leaves
and then it starts again but that is
something that the school's
infrastructure team are very cognizant
of and it may well be that as part and
parcel of talking about you know this
project in a wider sense next week but
also the forthcoming leisure project
that we touch on that base as well and
as you know there are other ambitions to
talk about footpath improvements as well
as access improvements it required
[ __ ] here just make a comment yes that's
that's good that's all good stuff now I
think one of the one of the things that
hopefully we've all learned from from
this bid is that the community needs to
be involved much earlier as I've spoken
to to Christine about the aspirations
with the Parish Council to have a trim
trail and various other things on the
school site this could all have been
this could all have been put together
and thought about at the same time but
unfortunately it wasn't so I think in
future we need to make sure that if
there's a big sale bid coming through
that there needs to be a wide debate
locally about about what can be gained
from that not just one specific item but
the wider issues need to be agreed in
the run-up to the to the sill bid being
made
and I just come back on that so as
you'll be aware or you may be aware
we've done quite a lot of work over
September October and November with the
joint member panel for amendments to the
SIL expenditure framework and one of the
main planks of that was to try and
achieve exactly what you've said this
morning which is you know a broad
discussion at a very early stage with
key people who need to be in the room so
that we can capture all the localized
issues and then bring them forward at
the same time as developing the projects
so hopefully when SIL bids come forward
in future it would have been a
comprehensive look at the whole process
it's not to say that consultation didn't
occur in respective of this project but
you know from our conversations which
had been outside this room I understand
where you're coming from and hopefully
the meeting on the 14th of January is a
step forward in in that direction cancer
medicine thank you oh I just want to
pick up a couple of points that were
raised by my neighbor council field
there is clearly is confusion about the
concepts of catchment areas because even
in your response you talked about
nearest schools now parts of my ward the
nearest school is star plant and that's
where they get a free bus - so there
there is a bit of confusion about what
is the catchment and what is just the
nearest school and in response to the
query about funding a private company
who run an Academy it may well be that
that is government policy that that
money comes from public purse to go to
private companies but are there any
guarantees or insurances that in it for
the unlikely I'm not saying it's likely
to happen but as the school gets large
amounts of funding from a SIL bid from
the public money if they just decided to
close sell up they would get a vast
profit so is there
come back on that I am so it's the the
reason that trusts don't themselves get
funding direct from government for
providing school places they get funding
for their condition and for their
revenue costs but it still remains
suffix responsibility to provide the
school places so that's why it's it's
with us and that's why we're submitting
the bid the building I guess which
remains an education establishment and
if for any reason that trust was found
not to be suitable than the regional
Schools Commissioner would then step in
and ensure that those places were
provided by another trust it wouldn't be
that they could just sell up the
buildings and and be gone that the
regional Schools Commissioner would then
at that point step in and ensure that
the places were there was a continuation
of those places being provided wasn't
really talking about the places I was
talking about the vast amount of money
that we're giving them that if they
effectively they are increasing the
value of their property if it's owned by
an Academy trust their property will now
be that be more valuable than it was
before
at the expense of the public purse if
they were to sell at the building light
whatever they're selling it to another
Academy they could make vast amounts of
profit out of public purse they they
remain a charity so I don't know I don't
know how it would work it's not it's not
been something that we've come across
certainly in Suffolk or that I know of
nationally but one would think that as
they are a charity that that wouldn't be
permitted by the Charities Commission I
would have thought but I'm no expert on
on academies and and what would happen
in that instance I'll try and assist I'm
not an expert on charities law or an
expert on academies but I know a little
bit about both and essentially as a
charity that money is ring-fenced and
they don't have shareholders and so the
money doesn't go anywhere in the
that they were to go bankrupt obviously
if they went bankrupt the money goes to
pay off their debtors but essentially
any supplementary that money's left over
at the end are ring front standstill
charitable funds they can't be lost into
the ether anywhere and certainly not
into somebody's pockets the expectation
is that they're plowed back into further
charitable activity Thank You Arthur and
canceled a booster did you question
think about MJ yes just a another couple
of questions really not relating to
start and it's all I had to say one
isn't on the grant of planning approval
the the ring-fence monies for that we
every virtually every application
appears to get an application for
library funding and I think I've spoken
about this before but adding this Sun up
in fact I've missed another ten thousand
by the looks of it I'd count what I'd
highlighted that she had a hundred and
ninety two thousand six hundred and
seventy two and I suspect now that's
another it's over the two hundred
thousand with the extra ten percent at
ten thousand rather just wondering to it
it seems a lot of expenditure on
libraries especially given the situation
with libraries at the moment when many
are volunteers I understand obviously
they've got the candy you've got
buildings to maintain which which
obviously probably contributes to some
of that but I just wonder what sort of
area we have control in that expenditure
please okay so when planning
applications come in consultations
happen with in this case Suffolk County
Council they give an indication of what
infrastructure needs they need to be
taken care of as far as the planning
application is concerned and they may
indicate that they need a contribution
for
libraries provision that then is
considered as part of the planning
application process in terms of delivery
and moving on from that we regularly
meet each month with people like Joe and
other people in the infrastructure team
at Suffolk County Council and we talk
about infrastructure whether it be
education libraries waste if they are
wanting to access money from a SIL point
of view it's not ring-fenced to
libraries they have to make a bid and it
has to be about what that infrastructure
will deliver and you know how that
stacks up against planning application
consultations that were submitted and
indeed what it will deliver for the
infrastructure of the area so it's not a
given that that money will necessarily
be required for in for libraries it may
well be in this particular case
obviously there the infrastructure that
we're considering at the moment is for
education it's a priority in the
infrastructure delivery plan if we get
oversubscribed with bids coming forward
then difficult decisions would have to
be made and we would look to our
infrastructure priorities and our
council strategies to inform what may be
most important in the scheme of things
so far there are no discussions taking
place about library school improvements
at all we've only had one library
provision or one library Sylphide made
which came forward by Thurston Parish
Council that was not with Suffolk County
Council on board and it was about
portable equipment which the scheme
doesn't lend itself to so that bid was
not taken forward just as supplemental
on libraries and the niobe services and
industrial and Provident society set up
some years years ago by the council sill
would only be able to fund physical
infrastructure so the extent which
volunteers are staffing libraries across
the county or anything like that is kind
of on the side of any decision-making
that you'd need to make about SIL
because broadly speaking that would be
about the building itself or perhaps its
car parking or something along those
lines rather than the actual staffing
often that the IB service itself just
one last one student madam chairman if I
might really I think this is probably
directed at Tom the seeders Park area
that I believe was a strategic site in
the first place and I was just wondering
if it was I was getting Syl now and
seders Park was a strategic site but it
was delivered as a strategic site prior
to Syl having been adopted so sue was
adopted in April 2016 and seen his park
was largely kind of 95 percent built out
at that stage so it was the strategic
sites that were identified within the
stone market area action plan that were
zero rated for sill so for example
Ashley's Farm Union Road
and then a couple of others there was
zero rated for seal purposes so as
development comes forward on Cedars Park
now if there's a little bit of infill
within one of the areas some of the very
very later phases that coming forward
are syllable because the bits of Cedars
Park that are left are not strategic in
nature if that makes sense so when it
was first put forward for planning it
was a strategic site but at that time
the council didn't have an adopted sill
regime when the council came to adopt
its sill regime see this park was
already built out so it wasn't included
as one of the strategic sites that was
zero rated at that time so if it was
slightly long-winded way of saying thank
you for that gorilla Thank You chair um
the the question in the answer about the
libraries makes me want to ask another
question about libraries if in if in ten
years time say there's been no call on
the money that's been taken into SIL at
the request of Suffolk County Council
that you know in our committee reports
we see that the so many new houses gives
rise to so much and made in terms of
cash for libraries if nothing is if
nothing is provided does does any cell
money get lost I guess not I just like
some some reassurance on that and then
the mention of Ashley's phone makes me
want to ask about because that's that's
possibly gonna what you shouldn't have
done that
makes me wonder whether that's going to
contribute to Ward's toe up in high
school since quite clearly that's at
some point not now but at some point
would that because there be presumably
section 106 on Ashley's phone rather
than so I'm I've got this completely
wrong if I could just have it some sort
of explanation because just as most of
the youngsters on Cedar's Park walk or
cycle to drive their car to stow up in
high school I guess appeal from a common
as well
so through your chair announces so on to
take your second point first ashes farm
that will be through a section 106 in
all likelihood provided that it all
depends on how sites move forward within
the Jorden local plant because obviously
we've got the strategic sites were
identified in prior documents but in
essence if Ash's farm comes forward as a
strategic site then it would be section
106 and then money would be secured for
school places and probably wouldn't be
identified exactly where that would be
spent so the money would be secured and
that would be X amount per student who's
coming forward on the library issue sill
is collected based on square meter
charge and can be spent on any within a
list of different types of community
infrastructure so albeit the county
council make representations on their
planning application responses that
doesn't determine the amount of SIL that
is collected they are essentially
seeking to put a marker down in the sand
that they're going to come forward at
some point and ask in the future but we
collect the amount of SIL that we
collect regardless of whether those
requests are made or not and those
requests like I say they're a marker in
the sand but but members can spend so
monies on what they see as the
priorities to spend SIL monies on so the
fact that the County Council may have
across a range of different planning
applications asked for circa 200,000
pounds towards libraries doesn't mean
that they will get circa 200,000 pounds
towards libraries it means that SIL has
been collected and at some point a bid
will come forward for an appropriate
funding towards a library given local
circumstances or extra demand or
whatever so that link that used to exist
between consultation requests and
section 106 negotiation doesn't exist
with community infrastructure leve
if you don't mind I'd like to ask a
question and not so much about SIL but
about libraries as well on that subject
and independent
for instance the library moved out of
its its own building and into a
classroom in the school thereby using up
a school classroom so presumably at some
point they will be applying for SIL to
fund another classroom it's not
clear-cut as that so so the library
moved from somewhere within
Debenhams into this school and so yes it
has taken up space within the school but
whether that would have been an
acceptable location for library
provision or not I don't know but they
would be able to come forward for
additional school places in due course
if they have space to expand at the
primary school there which i think is
pretty limited in terms of its ability
to actually to to grow on the site
that's already located on so we just
have to just have to see as an
application came forward I will propose
a and a second any more questions can I
have a show of hands in favor thank you
unanimous
item 12 mca 1935 a regulatory reform
order disabled adaptations this is a
decision taken by the chief executive
during the pre-election period counselor
platinum Thank You chair I have a little
bit of background information for you on
this so if I the chief executive has
made a decision in conjunction with the
chairperson of the council under their
delegated powers whilst the cancer was
in the pre-election period the
regulatory reform housing assistance
England and Wales board a 2002 P ro and
gives local authorities the power to
develop their own policy to assist their
residents to maintain and adapt their
homes to ensure that they are safe and
suitable for them to live in the housing
the housing assistance policy has been
developed to allow Weber and mid Suffolk
District Council's to make best use of
their disabled physical facilities grant
DFG funding this will enable the
council's to meet their strategic
priorities and work collaboratively with
health and social care colleagues to
provide better outcomes for the
residents the housing assistance policy
have sets out how Baber
and we suffered District Council's will
offer assistance to disabled residents
to improve accessibility and to suitably
and to and suitably of their
accommodation the Hat allows Baber and
mid Suffolk District Council's to meet
the aspirations set out in their
corporate plan and homes and housing
strategies to ensure that everyone has a
suitable home and residents are able to
live as healthily safely and
independently as possible within
sustainable communities homes and
housing strategy 2019 the key objectives
of the housing assistance policy are to
ensure residents are able to live as
healthily safely and independently as
possible to help prevent hospital care
home or residential her
admissions to facilitate the prompt
discharge of residents from hospital to
prevent the need for increased
expenditure elsewhere in the suffix
system include in health and social care
the main changes include increasing the
mag's non means-tested to 7500
introduction of a 10,000 discretionary
DFG to top-up the 30,000 mandatory DFG
totalling 40,000
of up to 7,500 which is not means tested
the policy has now been implemented and
will be carefully monitored to measure
the success of introducing additional
options to try and reduce the DFG
underspend Thank You chair do you have
any questions
Kesler booster
yes and I have just noticed that the
last paid page hundred - refers to Baber
rather than mid Suffolk all in favor
oh yes my apologies proposed it and a
seconder all in favor
thank you meeting closed at 11:38 thank
you everybody